[Music]
it's been two weeks since Robert Muller
finished his investigation and found
what many suspected
well a few suspected what some of us
suspected it pretty vehemently from the
very beginning there was no collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
government of Russia
so to that extent the case is closed but
members of Muller's team want to
continue the allegations in a series of
leaks to the New York Times they have
complained that the report despite
finding no criminal activity should be
released because it is quote damaging to
the White House in other words
prosecutors working for the federal
government no longer see their job as
enforcing the law instead the point is a
political vendetta and an attempt to
influence narratives about people they
dislike how does it make you feel is
that a proper role of a prosecutor
working for the federal government Glenn
Greenwald co-founded the intercept and
he joins us thank Lynn thanks very much
for coming on what do you make of this
most recent New York Times story about
what apparently is in the report we
haven't seen well it's similar to the
journalism that has fueled the
three-year hoax that has drowned us
discourse namely that the New York Times
The Washington Post gives anonymity to
totally unknown people to make claims
that are completely bereft of any
specifics unaccompanied by any evidence
whatsoever so that it's impossible to
analyze and then journalists see it and
then start celebrating online on social
media and cable news as though it's some
sort of a smoking gun I don't really
have personally any problem with having
the Moller report published and so I
don't think that in this case a special
counsel is just acting as a prosecutor
they're also there to say what actually
happened I think we'd all benefit from
that so that we don't have to have CIA
leaks trying to manipulate our brain but
the one thing we do know Tucker about
this report like we know very little but
the one thing we do know that they've
said is that these complaints from these
anonymous leakers whoever they are these
are anonymous objectors they're not
complaining about the section of bars
letter that reported that Muller found
no collusion they're only complaining
about the part where Muller said it's
impossible to say one way or the other
whether Trump obstructed justice so it's
amazing that actually the part about the
no collusion got bolstered
because even these malcontent who are
complaining to the New York Times
anonymously are saying we don't have a
problem with the section family finding
no collusion we only have a problem with
the obstruction issue what about all the
people over the last two years who've
been dismissed and you're one of them as
agents of the Russian government where's
the justice for them where do they get
the reputations back I think one of the
things that we've seen over the last two
or three years is that journalism more
than ever is a profession of complete
groupthink and mob rule in part because
it's really difficult to be a journalist
these days because of financial
constraints big movie outlets are laying
off huge numbers of people so if you're
a young journalist the last thing you
want to do is stick your head up and
challenge the prevailing consensus
because you could lose your job or if
you lose your job you'd be really hard
to get another job and also Twitter
makes it so that journalists constantly
talk to one another and create these
sort of gangs that design that are
designed to punish anybody who
challenges their orthodoxies and I think
journalism has completely disgrace tit
self at the exact time that they're
claiming that a grave danger the
Republic is that Trump is demeaning
journalists they've done more to demean
their profession with this behavior
calling people Russian agents who
question them or Trump supporters or
apologist or denialists they have a
whole long line of accusations and new
terms to stigmatize anyone who questions
their dissent and it's really effective
for a lot of people who unlike us don't
have established platforms and there's
it's been really effective to prevent
them from being questioned or challenged
so here's a question I want to ask you
for two years
you're making your critique from the
left you're on the left and you're not a
Trump fan that's a that's a tough
position to take and you've maintained
it this whole time what what of why were
you able to maintain an independent
perspective on this when so many others
want you know it's amazing because if
you think about it the question is there
evidence to demonstrate that there was
collusion between the Trump campaign and
the Russian government is completely
bereft of ideology it doesn't matter
whether you're on the left or the right
you're just looking at evidence it's
just an obsessive illogical question and
one of the things that has happened is
that everything is so tribal eyes so
they actually want you if you're to
maintain your stand you're good standing
on the left toe lie they want they
they're demanding you eye they're
demanding you say that you see evidence
and you see a convincing case for a
conspiracy theory even if you don't
really see it I have to say that unlike
establishment journalists like Jeremy's
gala Matt Taibbi and myself who have the
protection of being established there
were a lot of young journalists like
Michael Tracy and Aaron's right hey and
a bunch of others who are very
vulnerable who have the courage to incur
the wrath of this this profession in
order to do what journalists should do
which is to say what it is that they
think without any fear of who it would
anger is in very few of them are willing
to do that natives are of a lot of
credit for that I agree completely we've
had Tracy on the show a number of times
another brave a brave journalist Glenn
Greenwald thank you very much okay
thanks Tucker